The joe rogan experience.
Do you,
do you smoke pot with strangers?
No.
Me Neither.
No,
I don't.
If I don't know he might.
It's,
it's too much risk.
Sorry.
I tell people I don't,
I quit smoking it really,
and I usually don't.
I have to really know where the source of the weeders from before.
Before I'll accept it.
Then I'll give it friends of mine,
you know,
this is where I got this shit.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I do.
I'm like,
it's just certain people that I get high with that I know.
But I mean,
it's unfortunate,
but I've had,
I know one guy that definitely came up to me that was a cop in Cleveland.
I'm positive.
I just knew something was going on,
you know?
He's asking me where I could get DMT.
Oh,
and the way he was asked,
he said we had a crew cut.
I looked like a trend.
They did MMA and I'm looking at this dude and I'm like,
you want what?
Strange guy that looks like a cop asked me where to get illegal drugs.
I went when talking about,
I once had two cops work their ass off for me.
It was funny,
I had a nightclub in Canada.
Yeah,
we're teaching men.
And then I had to diet clubs in,
in one cut closed down and saw it and they sold the building.
So then I moved,
I had a back room,
you know,
so I was fixing up a back room,
did take over the other club and next thing you know I got to a man and a girl
with headbands,
they come up stairs and they're like,
they're not hippies by no means.
The headbands looked like a costume look like they're going trick or treating it
like a,
this is how they dress swimming.
So he said,
so,
so what's going on up here?
And I said,
well,
I'm just putting the club together.
He says,
I need some help.
I said,
yeah,
actually I do.
And so,
okay,
so they're,
they're in there helping,
you know,
what were you thinking at this time?
I'm looking at him thinking,
wow,
I could use the help.
Who knows,
I'm not going to pay him anything.
You know,
maybe let them in the club leader pre,
you know,
so they're moving tables and washing floors and so weird.
They just show up and start with work.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they were working and good workers too.
You know,
the more I look at him and I said,
these aren't hippies,
hippies will hide behind a wall to see if the,
or they're working whole camera to here,
you know.
So.
So they worked and then we had a little break,
you know,
and we're sitting around talking.
So I said,
where are you from?
Oh,
they're from Saskatchewan.
You have been here out here long.
Oh,
a couple of days.
So,
um,
so,
it'd be up.
We've got high.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Get high on the time as well.
Ever done acid?
They said,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
I love acid.
Yeah.
Nice.
Well,
tell me about your first acid trip.
The guy goes,
I don't remember.
He said,
I said,
just a minute,
I gotta go to the bathroom and I went to the bathroom.
I did a little dance.
Their carbs,
they're carbs through fucking cops.
That's hilarious.
I went back,
I said,
well let's get to work.
We got a lot of work to do here.
So you just put them to work.
So he scrubbed the floor,
man,
I had him,
there's head bedrooms soaking wet with sweat man,
their work their ass off.
And then I got on the phone and phoned everybody knew,
cause we used to say the door lady used to sell weed right at the door.
Right.
That that does kind of club.
It was so,
so then the club filled up and they stayed the whole time.
They didn't go home and change or anything.
You've got their little headbands or why or did they change?
No,
I think they did change.
They went home,
they okay,
we'll see you back later.
And then he came sat together and they look like recruits.
We looked like recruits.
I mean they were so,
so,
so out of place.
And I told everybody is everybody would walk by and like they were on on
display.
They just walk by and look at the cubs they were looking at at and walk.
But it was so,
everybody kept an eye on them.
And if you wanted to smoke weed,
just made sure he knew where the cops were.
Yeah.
Well,
first of all,
you don't do anything.
You know,
they're cops,
so,
right.
So no one does anything.
So no one did anything.
[inaudible] Claire and the Lady,
you know,
all of a sudden that was the cleanest club in town.
So now at the end,
did you ever let them know that you knew they were calling?
No,
no,
no.
Don't give that up.
I just went,
how'd you end the night?
Well,
they just left.
They just left.
They couldn't make a connection and they knew they got spotted.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm cool.
You look cool.
But there's a lot of people that he,
a fucking car.
Okay.
Freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on,
Ladies and gentlemen?